people will be watching this video with
interest because we haven't seen
Baghdadi since he appeared back in 2014
which was when he gave her a sermon at
the main mosque in Mosul declaring the
start of the caliphate and since then as
you mentioned there have been multiple
reports of his death there was a very
credible report a few years back that
he'd been badly wounded
so intelligence analysts journalists
people who follow this part of the world
and this group will be watching and
studying in interest what he's saying
and the message that he's giving you can
see him in the picture he's he's looking
he doesn't look in great health he's got
a long gray beard very different to the
thick of it he cut back in 2014 when he
had a trim black beard so clearly the
past five years have taken their toll on
him not surprisingly and he has a
message to the West he says that the
battle of Islam and its people against
the Crusaders and their followers is a
long battle is really this sense that
while yes the Caliphate the
self-declared Caliphate of Islamic state
has fallen and it fell last month
following us-led efforts backing Iraqi
and Syrian forces to regain that land
that had been taken by is he's saying
that while it's fallen his followers
will continue to wage this this war as
he sees it he also says in words that
are not actually on camera but you hear
his voice saying that that there
Srilanka attacks last Easter Sunday were
in response for the fall of the goose
now that is the final stronghold of the
final foothold the tiny patch of land
relatively speaking in Syria that was
the last stretch of territory held by
Islamic state until it fell to
western-backed Syrian forces
few weeks ago he's saying that the the
the his fighters fought bravely is
claiming and saying that they will
avenge the the sort of suffering that
they say took place now this video it
must be it must be under underlined as a
propaganda video released by Islamic
states media arm it cut its veracity
can't be independently confirmed but it
looks real it looks like it's been
recently shot and it does look like what
it says it is Baghdadi
appearing for the first time in five
years